Okay, now we are actually live. I got a
call literally right when I went to turn
the stream on.
Maybe we figure out something with where
we put the data set.
We build the docker. We push the docker.
We test it. We fix the trailer. We're
done. That's it.
Uh
this.
You can totally treat this as one
syllable, right?
This to me is one syllable.
Hey, Liberty.
When I wrote this, nobody even
questioned it.
Yeah.
I don't know why
I can easily just do this. I'll just do
that.
I'll go fix that now. And the um the
other stuff
What do we have to do? What do we got to
do? We got to go check sweeps.
Okay, we get a full sweep on tower
climb.
That's nice.
Jesus. 1.2 bill in the sweeps though,
Spencer.
Oh, good job.
Yeah, that's still pretty that's pretty
good.
I think we're fine then.
CL drive.
One, two, three,
nine.
All right, we got it.
There is
Let's do the restroom real quick. While
this process is
Here's
the restroom real quick with this
process.
Oh, I guess it's fast. Well, then we'll
launch it.
All right. Uh hopefully that trans I'll
be right back.
right.
Uh oh. Okay, cool. The drive end is
working nicely.
That's what we want.
It's not that slow either. That's like
decently quick.
Okay, that's not bad.
Hey, Call, welcome.
We're just figuring out a couple things
with the release.
21.
Our word's a little janky.
That's 20. And this is the one that was
jank.
What should I call this? Data set
constellation
experiments.
tomorrow. Yeah, no screenshots until
then. Thank you.
Are we back?
Stupid thing, man.
Hello, chief puffing officer. First time
seeing you with headphones.
Sometimes I have music. This is the last
few hours of work before release.
Been a week since I
What have you been up to?
upskill an AI
do most of my homeworkations.
I can write some of the best prompts.
Like I hope you don't mean just like how
to use language models by um upskilling
an AI.
Like using language models to just do
your homework for you is the opposite.
You're literally just screwing yourself
out of learning.
like upskilling an AI would be like go
take CS231N,
go train a few different models,
you know, go train models, go do a
little bit of supervised learning, go
reimplement a couple of papers, go read
some papers, build a little RL
environment. That's these types of
things. Um, starting from the basics,
like the basics is not how to use
language models since she said prompts.
The basics would be like go train linear
regression
like go understand and train linear
regression.
It's definitely good you want to learn
and you should learn and it it takes
effort. Um, but just be careful because
there are a lot of people advertising
shortcuts now that ultimately just screw
you over. Like the people that are just
prompting language models and not deeply
learning stuff are going to be
worthless.
making train would be too much.
Yeah, just be careful with those TMA
because like a lot of the things on the
information on how to use angle, how to
learn AI by using language models,
they're just grifters.
Like
using language models takes absolutely
no skill and all of the fancy like oh
agents this parallel that you know
skill.md like it's all [ __ ]
So, make sure that you're actually
getting people who are giving you real
stuff
like Car Path is not his new blogs. He's
kind of gone off the deep end lately,
but his old blogs on like Pong. If you
read here, this guide
here, this has links to a whole bunch of
useful resources right here.
AI is something that you actually kind
of do need to just learn deeply,
especially the engineering component.
There's really no getting around just
like doing some low-level dev.
It's not that difficult if you can put
in some time though. Like a lot of it
isn't at least.
Uh, I do not have the chat open, but
it's just X. It's just like Jay Suarez
on X and you just click my articles tab.
I have lots of them here. Most of them
are these technical things. I allow
myself like one fitness article once in
a while. It's important, but other than
that, it's all technical stuff.
And it's to a variety of different um
different skill levels. Like some of
them are more accessible than others.
How do you develop custom policies? Uh
it's a little bit obnoxious. We have one
example with Ocean. The code is not very
clean, but it's not that that difficult.
Uh the main thing is that you're
responsible def for defining the um all
of the buffers that you need for your
activations and stuff. I I will say
though that the good news is even though
it's a bit harder to do custom policies
now, uh the default policies solve all
but one environments better than we'd
solve them with the custom encoders in
3. So we depend far less on custom
encoders now.
Like the new model is just really good
and ultimately I hope we depend even
less on him.
This pisses me off, man. Am I like,
is there just an easy way to fix this? I
kind of don't want to add an extra file
in here for it.
Oh, you know what? This is actually
probably correct.
What are we working on?
So I just uploaded the experiment data
here. Uh this is now good. So we can go
pull this policy.
check message.
That might not be
okay.
Yeah, I was a little like h pick me
another map while I figure this out.
fencer.
Actually, never mind. This is not bad.
It's only 2 MB.
2 MB is livable.
This is why it loads so [ __ ] slow,
though.
Um,
no. That's not impressive.
AI has just become such an unserious
field.
Good.
I'll have to fix this.
This will be quick though.
What was the script that I had for this
thing?
trailer trailer.c
Yeah. What do you make your trailers in?
You're telling me you don't make your
trailers in sea.
Perfect.
Now I do have to stick it into a video
editor just for the sake of um
I have to stick the uh whatchamacall the
rest of the they're like some videos
that get overlaid
but all the effects are in Okay.
The the explanation for this is very
simple.
If you look at um if you look at the
website, it's a fast and sane
reinforcement learning library. So, I
put all the sanity into the library, and
I didn't leave any for myself.
Okay, we should do a quick um
a quick like
uh breakout solve, right?
Just needed to start the container.
Nice.
Okay, so this goes here.
Put it like this. Maybe
that about the right scale.
Yeah, but this is the wrong scale, so
this one's better.
Boom.
Thank you, Spencer. I will snag that.
I'm finishing the trailer.
Did you commit the bin? Yes, you did.
Very good. Thank you very much.
Get yourself some good brunch
and happy Easter to you.
you're still on. Um,
I think this will take me two hoursish
of work probably if I'm good. Maybe a
little less. We'll see. If not, you can
message me. I don't have any
celebrations. I'm kind of just stuck
here alone.
PR hell will be after take a break.
We're not doing PR hell jazz. We're
doing like chill little by little merge
cool things. I'm done crunching. I've
done my crunching.
Oh, I can turn the desktop audio on so I
can share this with you.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second. Hey, programmer sailor. Welcome.
I got to get a bench set in real quick.
Keep myself sane. Last couple hours. I
got 245 for six earlier today. Let's see
if we can replicate that feat.
For unless there's some massive Jess,
there's always hard work to be done.
There's always hard work to be done.
It is the one constant in my life.
No torchel. True. That's less like
grinding hard and more grinding on like
things that are just disgusting.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
How's this for trailer guys?
>> Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
When I ran puffer, my fans turn on.
Yeah, it'll sit at 100% UDL for any of
the uh the ends that are not [ __ ]
Basically, the only time it's not at
100% util is if the end is unoptimized.
Like if if the NV is slow, then it'll
bottleneck and your GPU fans get a
break.
100% GPU.
Hell yeah.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
agents at 20 million. That was super
loud steps per second with Puffer Lib's
pure CUDA back end. And it's probably
fine.
It's a little tough to know because my
desktop audio levels are going to be
different from um the video, but I can
send this to a Spencer
for evaluation.
music was what music was loud? Oh [ __ ]
I hope I don't get DMCA over that.
Um I like just flicked my music on to
like get the sound levels.
I probably won't. It's a random um
It's a random game track.
Why does it not let me [ __ ] attach
files?
cuz it's a little weird to not have this
one in here.
combines mining with highway
connections.
million steps per second with
Pufferlib's pure CUDA back end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining with highway
connections.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Pufferlib's pure CUDA back
end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
hardware efficient aritecture combines
mining with highway
connections.
Aritecture combines mining with highway
auto update with sweep. So you do need
to rerun
uh so you need to reprocess the data
files but you don't need to recompile
constellation
Um, and also if we were to port the
update script to C, it would run way
faster. Um, the the caching script is
kind of slow.
I can only do so much.
It is a pouring rain.
mood.
steps per second with Puffer Lib's pure
CUDA back end.
pure CUDA back end.
Our heart.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining with highway
connections.
hardware efficient architecture combines
mining with highway connections. LIB's
pure CUDA back end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA
backend.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Highway connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff
puff up your reinforcement learning.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
Start
to puff up your reinforcement learning.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second.
Pufferlib's pure CUDA back end.
Our hardware efficienc
needs to be adjusted.
combines mining with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps
train agents At 20 million steps per
second with Puffer's pure CUDA backend,
our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with constellation. Our new
the crickets like a little grading.
I need like a more constant one.
dashboard that runs locally
and in your browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's pure CUDA back
end.
Our hardware
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Pufferlib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Pufflib's pure CUDA back
end. Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Mingru with highway
connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
Now featuring 20 plus environments to
puff up your reinforcement learning.
I working on
final release?
Final assets for release. And then we
got to get the Docker.
What the [ __ ] is auto playing?
[ __ ]
Oh, look. That looks way better, right?
Lower res with um less compression.
I should bother learning the uh the f
ofmpeg commands.
Okay.
Uh, I'm going to upload these to
drive.
I'd like to not open my Google Drive on
the stream though. Let me just move
over.
all the Python seems to have vanished
from 40. Yes, it has.
Yes, it has. It's gotten much easier.
No [ __ ] Python.
There is some Python but not for these M
specifics.
done.
All we have to do is
The docker.
The docker is the last thing to be done.
Oh, and the drive end on the website.
I'm stupid.
Guess the
How do I play with constellation? Do not
post this on socials until I post the uh
the release tomorrow. It is uh it is
here for the people who know where to
find it.
constellation html
and I'm going to update the uh the file
on it as well in a moment that it will
have Drive
Uh, well, that's not an Easter egg init.
There will be a button. I just haven't
pushed the button because I'm not going
to push the button until the official
launch.
Oh, I think I deleted the snake policy,
didn't I?
That
Uh you should not have two binding.h and
C files. Where do you see that in?
If so, I will delete extras. What ends?
Will we be able to adjust window size?
Uh not locally, but you can do this.
I'll show you.
Uh
Hang on.
So on this version, you can just like
use your web zoom and it works.
This apparently does it scale with the
window size now.
two
in total one binding.h. No, there's not
an ish. There should be no binding.h.
What end has a binding.h? It's only a
binding C.
X is still weird.
No idea.
Okay. Yeah. So, now it works, right?
Spencer made it um adjust apparently.
which is fine. It'll be a little weird
when it resizes. It's going to look best
around 1080p. It's rendering 1080p.
Uh, well, web will only go on the web
version, Jess. You have to open that
with an index HTML. But it should be a
reasonable size. It's 1080p. Like all
modern screens should be reasonably
1080p.
Why are there binding files for
everything?
Yeah, constellation is nice. I'm very
proud of how it turned out. I actually,
this was not uh the hardest thing in
this update. This was actually the
easiest thing in this update. And I knew
that we weren't really going to have
anything visual otherwise. But I wanted
to do what like one really cool visual
thing to show off um like this is kind
of a cool way to show off the speed in a
sense cuz like you get all these
experiments from that,
you
Oh, come on. It crashes when you do uh
right click now.
I don't need to think about this, do I?
I can just like
I had that happen. Additional data
boring the original.
Okay, I'll go look.
Uh, you can dead click on it, which is a
little annoying.
Not bad.
Okay.
What do we have on the read me right
now?
The Discord just disappeared.
Not good.
So, the Discord uh button just broke
apparently at some point
because the Discord button is like down
everywhere.
Works here.
relaxed for launch.
I'm feeling good. B I'm like
I mean I've really been pretty
disciplined with my schedule for
everything else um the last several
days. So, I've been making it through
He like he's doubling down on that [ __ ]
up.
When I say do everything static memory,
I don't mean like literally static
memory. I mean it's like all right. The
memory should be known after you init
the program, not literally when you
compile it.
There you go. Constellation in your
browser.
Uh why is it the full data set?
Well, shipping 40 megs of experiments
doesn't seem ideal to me. I don't know
about you.
I think I might have [ __ ] that one up,
guys. Just a bit.
One megabyte experiments though. We can
totally add
He is quite entertaining, but he kind of
bumbles his way through a lot of crap.
I think he's relying way too much on the
language models
at the moment.
only fish.
I mean, to be fair, we could probably
make that thing work now.
Oh, those are cool.
That's really cool.
Yeah, you don't need [ __ ] five
fingered hands for um
I don't actually know what the optimal
number is. I just know it's not the full
freaking articulated hand with all the
tiny parts.
Boom. Full data set.
It's only laggy because this is over
SSH, guys.
This is like this is entirely running
over SSH on one of the machines behind
me.
Okay. So, I just have to go figure out
the uh the Docker perms.
We win.
Yay. The container.
The container is being pushed.
Well, what do you all think? Puffer
release.
This is officially here. This is the
docker. This is what you need.
This is a perfect time to use the
restroom and get a bench set in.
We'll be right back.
Hopefully I don't have to redo this.
I'm going to need all of you to help
test the Docker
and um don't tweet anything on 40 until
tomorrow. Tomorrow's the official
launch.
This session here is just for the stream
viewers.
Get it early.
Got training equipment for the agents
and training equipment for me.
other architectures. Well, I'm doing
significant research on other
architectures.
Um,
I think there are a few people doing out
there stuff, but I think at this point
the main
money behind everything is going into
the really big architectures. Now, you
don't necessarily need a lot of money
for other stuff to do that. Um,
it seems like
at least with what people are doing at
the moment,
a lot of the architectures are kind of
similar in Perf and it's more the data
and then the RL stuff,
but I haven't been following it closely
to know if that's still the case since I
last checked.
right, almost done. Two gigs
and we'll test this and we are done.
Finally.
Oh, she co-ounded thinking.
I know that.
But wait, am I thinking of someone else
who had the the RL blogs?
Is there a GitHub or Docker profile?
Puffer.ai. AI,
GitHub, Discord,
uh there's Docker. You are catching us,
James. This is the day before launch. So
everything is in beta right now. And uh
this Docker container here is being
pushed right now. So this should in
theory work as soon as uh as soon as
this thing syncs after this is pushed.
I also have to push the um the Docker
repo here.
I'm on 4B. I don't know what I should
like what would I do with a 4B model?
Can't really do anything with that.
All right.
Ah, the darker.
I said four hours of work today. It's
been precisely four hours.
I think we're done.
I think we're done, guys.
Um, let's write a quick post in the
Discord.
So, if a couple of you wouldn't mind
just like trying it out
and uh letting me know if it works,
it should work. But if there's anything
that's broken,
1.4 gigs of VRAM,
one gig of RAM.
trained in Eval in 4 seconds over SSH
single 5090
you'll be able to get 10 mil plus steps
per second. So, this will train in under
you train this in like 10 seconds on a
less than $2,000 machine easily.
It doesn't feel real that we're done,
you know? It just doesn't feel real that
this is done.
Oh, and actually on the real website,
I can't even tell that the color is
slightly off here.
It's actually really tough to even see
the color being off.
I think I'm just done. The puffer fish
will get fixed soon anyways.
sorry the puffer on GitHub, folks. I
think I'm going to call it. I think
that's it for the stream. I think I get
to actually go just rest for a little
bit. I get to take a few hours off. I'm
traveling tomorrow. I also have to pack
a little bit.
I'll do that as well. I'm going to pack
for tomorrow. And uh I'm traveling
Monday and Tuesday.
I'm going to basically do the launch in
the morning tomorrow.
Probably won't stream or anything, but I
will do the launch in the morning
tomorrow.
Um
everybody of course post that
everywhere, etc., etc.
I will go catch a train
and I will be back uh Tuesday night.
I'll be posting a couple articles
in the process of that or in the
meanwhile I should say
This has been eight months of grind
900 plus hours streamed.
Um,
I had never I'd only done a tiny bit of
CUDA before this. There's a ton of stuff
to learn.
Basically, we had to rip through the
entirety of Torch.
We discovered a new architecture.
We made a super fast visualization
toolkit.
We so did every benchmark.
We 5x the speed of puffer.
and we've set the stage for a whole new
wave of progress in reinforcement
learning which will start in just about
a week or two once I get some rest.
Thanks everyone.